I'm Ken Hinkley I managed the epic
research group here at Microsoft
Research quick plug for my group we do
cool stuff I'll give you a quick
sampling here for today's talk I wanted
to focus on something I call the scene
but unnoticed so these can be behaviors
that occur between people but
particularly here I'm talking about our
mundane interactions with physical
objects you approach you Prout your
device you grasp it you pick a lot pick
it up you might angle it towards someone
or yourself you put it down these are
things that sort of happen every day and
can be sensed by devices but first you
kind of have to pay yourself the to pay
attention so that you can observe these
scene but on notice things in everyday
life it might just be during an everyday
walk in the park right so um so for
example take a closer look here at the
woman at the center who's reading a book
and note how her book sort of carves out
this cocoon with this two angled pages
and the little world that carves out
with within and this is just one example
but it shows how the posture and the
placement of mundane objects like her
book or our digital devices can shape
personal space and also steer the
attention of other people so let me give
you a few examples that point to many of
these overt attributes and they're
totally practical from watering devices
to sentence but of course like all
proper research this line of work began
with anyone want to venture a guess
where it started I'll call you guys are
brilliant no idea failure okay good
guess but wrong again with the cat
this is mr. Clio is my favorite cat ever
and he's thinking about maybe getting
off the bed and this rainy Saturday way
back in 1999 and I was playing with the
sort of fancy mobile devices of the day
and it struck me that you know compared
to my cat my device was not so
impressive but it's completely unaware
of his environment whereas my cat's
aware of sounds and objects
it's my devices totally oblivious to my
presence my cat knows if I walk in the
room it likes to be petted and overall
the experience with the device is
selfish and inconsiderate and of course
with my cat wealth you use a cat
so I want to show you a little video
that came out of this what I have here
from the year 1999 is the 100 mobile
computer it has this one's a little bit
unusual because I've been doing some
work on it has some strange sensors
attached to it and in the top of all
these funky sensors these were carefully
crafted in place by ripping out the
compact flash slot and throwing it in
the trash picking up and looking at the
device turns on the power the sensors
respond only when you're holding the
device and looking at it so if you push
the device out of the way it will not
turn on similarly the device will not
turn on while in a briefcase or purse if
even if it's being shaken around the
user can set the display mode simply by
turning the device
whoa I'm not sure what happened there I
think there's been a bit of a glitch in
the timestream but bear with me here so
I can pick it up when I do so it
automatically turn itself on tilt the
device opponent or rotates hey that's
that's kind of cool well how the
animation gets so good I don't remember
doing that
in 1999 here all right so just sort of
the long history of some of these
projects that Microsoft research and we
have a bit of fun too more recently you
might have seen our latest device
announcements we're doing some cool
stuff with dual screen devices this also
has a long history at Microsoft Research
and in particular I want to talk about a
bit about sensing some of the basic
device postures that can transform
experiences on these kind of devices so
here back in 2009 I built this device
called the codex dual screen tablet
computer and in particular it explored
some of the physical affordances of
actually having these two hinge displays
together so I have another short video
on this and I apologize to interpreter
that I talk so fast in these videos dual
screen tablet computer accustomed date
on hinge between the displays afford
setting up the device in a variety of
postures embedded sensors automatically
adjust the displays and the software
functionality to suit the resulting task
context whether that means different
arrangements for individual work or
postures that afford collaborating with
another user the small folding form
factor makes the codecs extremely mobile
and versatile back in his office Joe
uses his codex as an electronic
scrapbook he does a quick search and
starts to explore what's there Joe
browses the photos side by side with his
notes then he grabs clipping all without
interrupting is primary note-taking
tasks overall the two screens of the
Codex afford a separation of concerns in
reading versus writing public versus
private and other partitions of task
roles and views the facile transitions
between usage context via sensed
postures enable own rich set of
possibilities without undue burden to
the
all right so it's just another quick
sampling of some of the fun products
done in this space I wanted to move on
to one final example here this one's a
little bit more recent it's a project we
did exploring what we call pre touch
which is sensing touch around and above
mobile devices so here again is one of
these you know a bit like the woman
holding the book this is another sort of
mundane scene you've probably seen a
million times maybe not in a window
strong granted but on a mobile device
it's just it's a hand holding a device
but if you ever really noticed what
people are doing in this kind of context
how they use their hands this there's a
lot of information here hiding in plain
sight so ask yourself what does it
really mean to touch a device and even
such a mundane scene like this it has
extraordinary clues to context and the
users intent so let me show you some
examples of how we can take advantage of
that we explore sensing for mobile
interaction this emerging modality uses
a self capacitive touchscreen to sense
multi-touch above the screen as well as
grip around the outer edges of the
device for example our prototype video
player has an ad-lib interface that
spontaneously presents interactive
elements just in the nick of time
initially there is no interface
the video is the focus of attention but
when the hand approaches this indicates
a change in context and so the controls
fade in yet the interface recedes into
the background when the user moves out
of proximity however if the user holds
the device one-handed only a subset of
the controls come forward and in a
manner particularly suited to the phone
while holding the device in the other
hand brings two controls to that side
instead with the second thumb a richer
set of options becomes available taken
as a whole our exploration of pre touch
hints that the evolution of mobile touch
may still be in its infancy with many
possibilities unbounded by the flatland
of the touchscreen yet to explore
all right so it gives you a sense of how
you even just holding a device is all
these sort of subtle little micro
contexts or sort of little context that
you can pick up and use that to adapt
the device to the situation so I've
talked a bit about this notion of the
scene but I noticed in mobile devices
and this is a natural vocabulary of
everyday gestures that are hidden in
plain sight so remember when you're kind
of walking around the world remember to
pay attention to what people are doing
their behaviors these little things and
open your eyes to these opportunities in
everyday life thanks very much
[Applause]
you